among prince andrew's close friends a
child sex trafficker and a prolific
paedophile
the duke of york travelled on jeffrey
epstein's private jet and mr epstein and
gelaine maxwell were invited to balmoral
and windsor castle
but it's the accusation prince andrew
sexually assaulted virginia dufrey three
times when she was 17 years old that is
at the heart of this case he denies
wrongdoing
he knows exactly what he's done and
i hope he comes clean about it thank you
the secret document revealed today shows
jeffrey epstein paid virginia du frey
500 000
in a 2009 settlement there is no mention
of prince andrew however it includes a
clause which says virginity frey does
release acquit satisfy and discharge
any other potential defendants from all
and all manner of
action now this is the clause which
prince andrews lawyers are likely to
argue means the whole case should now be
thrown out virginia dufrese team say
this document is irrelevant and the fact
that the prince isn't even mentioned
means he's not covered by it ultimately
it's up to the judge to decide if this
case should go ahead but if it does
expect a full civil trial in the autumn
in civil cases parties usually settle
before that happens
but some legal experts think one of the
parties in this case may be loath to do
that
virginia is already a multi-millionaire
because she was able to settle against
epstein's estate so there's less
pressure on her to take a settlement and
make the case disappear she's not as
needy as she might have been several
years ago in that sense this is the sort
of case where
virginia herself and her lawyers might
say to prince andrew we don't care how
much you pay we're not settling we want
the truth to be told we want to have a
trial
the next hearing in this case takes
place tomorrow tarnishing the start of
the queen's platinum jubilee year and
raising further questions about the
judgment of the man said to be her
favorite son